we're always hearing that being selfish
is one of the worst character traits
that anyone could possess it smacks of
greed entitlement and cruelty and yet
some of the reason we fail to have the
lives we should and thereby end up mean
bitter and irritable is because we're
suffering from an opposite problem an
excessive selflessness an exaggerated
modesty an over hasty deference to the
wishes of everyone but ourselves our
problem is that we're not selfish enough
we collectively get muddled because we
fail to distinguish between good and bad
versions of selfishness the good
desirable kind of selfishness involves
having the courage and self-awareness to
give priority to ourselves at particular
points the confidence to be forthright
about our needs not in order to harm or
reject other people but in order to
serve them in a deeper more sustained
and committed way over the long term bad
selfishness on the other hand operates
with no greater end in view and no
higher motive in mind we're not
declining to help so as to marshal our
resources to offer others a greater gift
down the line we just can't be bothered
unfortunately afflicted by confusion
about this distinction we frequently
fail to be brave enough about stating
our needs as clearly as we should with
disastrous results precisely for those
we're meant to serve for example in
order to be a good parent we may need to
have an hour to ourselves every day we
may need to take a long time in a hot
shower to mull over events we may need
to do something that seems a bit
indulgent like a life drawing or
clarinet lesson but because we may sense
how contrary to expectations these
desires can seem we might opt to stay
quiet about our requirements and just
get on with the job and so we grow
increasingly ragged angry and bitter
with those who rely on us a lack of
selfishness can turn us slowly into
highly disagreeable as well as
ineffective people good
selfishness grows out of an
unembarrassed understanding of what we
need in order to maximize our utility
for others as good selfish people we
accept what we require to develop our
abilities get our minds into the right
frame summon up our most useful powers
and organize our thoughts and feelings
so that they can eventually be helpful
to the world
we recognize that we will at select
moments have to back out of doing things
that people would very much like us to
do but we have no compunction about
politely explaining that we just can't
be there for them unlike the selfless
who will dutifully smile and help out
and then one day explode in vindictive
exhausted rage we know as kind edgar
ist's that we may be confused with a
mean-spirited but our innate conviction
of our sincerity lends us the calm to
pursue our aims politely in our own way
so as not to be accused of the wrong
sort of selfishness the trick is to
become a better ambassador of your
intentions we have to persuasively and
kindly convey to those around us that
we're not lazy or callous and indeed
we're not but we have to show them that
we will simply better serve their needs
by not doing the expected things for a
while sweet people run the strange but
highly important risk of becoming a
nuisance to other people by what sounds
like but really isn't a good idea always
putting others first as good selfish
people no sometimes putting oneself
first may actually be the best way to
serve others properly in the long run
you